I'm going to play something very
interesting for you today it's
delusional it's deranged it's backwards
as much of the American right wing is
but it opens up a very interesting
conversation a republican candidate for
Governor Mark Robinson who happens to be
black and this is very relevant to what
we're going to hear from him is in favor
of reparations
but not the kind you might think of what
Mark Robinson
says he wants for reparations is black
people should give white people
reparations as a thank you for ending
slavery
yes now I know you're saying wait but
David that doesn't make sense for so
many different reasons of course but
let's first listen to what he had to say
and it's full ridiculous glory and then
we will talk about it some people that
we're talking about
in this country they want to rep
ER face nobody owes you anything for
slavery
if you want to tell the truth about it
it is you who owes
it's you who owns whoa why do you owe
because somebody in those fields took
strikes for you
somebody after those fields were ended
and slavery was ended somebody had to
walk through Jim Crow for you
somebody fought Wars and died for you
somebody lived less than because they
didn't have what you have and they did
it for you
there are people in their graves right
now
and they are there because they were
willing to stand up and fight for you
those folks on the Edmond Pettus Bridge
carrying American flags take that Colin
Kaepernick
living in a society that he could
scarcely acknowledge something that he
has never known living with a bigotry
that none of us can imagine right
carried American flags on that bridge
and when they were hit upside the head
with night sticks and shot with water
hoses and knocked to the ground they got
up and picked those flags up and kept
marching all right so I guess he's
saying not only do black people today
oh white people reparations they also
owe earlier black folks who are no
longer alive reparations which is weird
so this is this is unreal stuff and this
is what happens when you just become a
contrarian for the sake of contrarianism
now I think that there are perfectly
reasonable critiques about reparations
and we've talked about them before you
can come down on either side as far as
reparations go but the idea that black
people owe white people money
for freeing them from slavery ignoring
that they were the ones enslaving the
black folks to begin with is really
something else it's like asking for
praise for putting out a fire that you
started and the other important thing to
remember is that many white people
including the slave owners didn't want
to end slavery he's sort of pretending
like listen white people ended slavery
so you should thank them no no no a
whole bunch of white people did not want
to end slavery and they lost the Civil
War over that
it's a wacky argument to make and by the
way
even after slavery was legally abolished
we still saw black folks facing
segregation of all kinds discrimination
oppression in the form of Jim Crow laws
systemic racism and so much of that
Legacy that we followed through hundreds
of years this is really wild and I'll be
totally honest with you
I don't even know if Robinson genuinely
believes this this is the virus the Mind
virus of contrarianism of if anybody on
the left is suggesting X then I need to
make clear that the opposite of X is
actually what we need I don't know
whether this is going to win them the
governorship or what but it is unreal to
see them saying these things out loud
and what's even crazier is people in the
crowd who decide to clap for it this
country has fallen very very far